latvia was ready to join the euro single
currency area on january first 2014 at a
meeting in brussels EU finance an
economy ministers adopted three
legislative files that make up the final
technical hurdle for the baltic state to
become the 18th member of the eurozone
crisis at yours on east takings of
measures to deal with a current
financial and economical crisis and
moreover there is confidence in eurozone
and eurozone is indeed enlarging so I
think it's a good day for boss for
Latvia for and for Europe a key decision
at the eco fin council was to set the
exchange rate of the national currency
into euros conversion rate was fixed at
zero point 70 to 80 for lats took one
euro this corresponds to the official
rate currently in use and Latvia as
prime minister says that decision could
bolster support among citizens for the
single currency change over next year
one of the arguments euro skeptics were
using was definitely some Quebec often
will convert lots to euros in some
different exchange rate and all the time
there were speculations about this
despite that boss government and bank of
Latvia repeatedly stated that it's going
to be according to the existing official
exchange rate well now today sake of
indecision approves it and I think it's
also additional step towards gaining
more confidence among public euro notes
and coins will be issued in Latvia on
january first the government plans a
massive publicity campaign over the next
six months to explain the practicalities
of the changeover such as what will
happen with people savings and how cash
will be converted